if we go through we're going to look at
some of the fine details across
the pages that we've just been looking
at so here we go these are the
conclusions uh if you go straight to the
end this i think is uh
the key judgment at the heart of this
report the senior leadership at the
center both political and official must
bear responsibility for this culture so
the big picture the big question about
this report is exactly what does that
mean in a in a situation where we are
told boris johnson isn't going to resign
simon case the head of the service civil
service isn't going to resign um
sue gray is doing this report
some months after she released an
interim report what's interesting about
all of her language when it comes to the
conclusions and she essentially says
that the key judgments that she made
last time still stand they pointed to
failings at the top of the civil service
and the top of the uh political machine
uh and she still stands by those the
question is what uh given the vast array
of information that she's putting in the
public domain uh we uh we get
uh in this report uh she says here in my
update i made a number of general
limited uh findings that update was the
thing that we saw on january the 31st
and she does say i am pleased progress
is being made in addressing the issues i
had raised i comment upon the
fragmentary and complicated leadership
structures in number 10 uh and she
basically says that things are going uh
a little bit better she says i found
that some staff had witnessed or been
subjected to behaviors at work which
they had felt concerned about but at
times felt unable to raise properties
that's interesting she's essentially
saying that the civil service here
didn't feel that they could challenge
the culture in some cases of illegality
uh that they were seeing all around them
because they didn't feel that they had
the confidence to do that uh i was made
aware of multiple examples of a lack of
respect and poor treatment of security
and cleaning staff now you'll remember
sky news reporting yesterday that in
some cases the security guards known uh
in number 10 as the custodians were
emailing to complain about the behavior
in number 10 after some of those parties
that we've been reading about
but uh clearly those complaints falling
on deaf ears and i think if they are
like there's any suggestion of
mistreating the cleaning stuff i think
that will uh send shockwaves across many
mps she says that was uh unacceptable
she says things have happened uh to
improve the situation since then uh but
she makes more recommendations about
alcohol in the workplace here's another
key conclusion on the next page uh the
matter of what disciplinary action
should now be taking while there is no
excuse for some of the behavior set out
here it is important to acknowledge that
those in the most junior positions
attended gatherings at which their
seniors were present or indeed organized
so in other words sugree is trying to
tell us that those higher up the
political chain
should bear responsibility but she is
not in the conclusions naming names
we'll be going through in a bit uh a
little bit later uh to get a sense of
whether or not she does in other bits of
the
uh report the annex essentially does
have a series of photographs this is the
19th of june 2020. now that was the
prime minister's birthday party uh
you'll remember that uh this is the
event that boris johnson got fined for
that individual there is simon case he's
the head of the civil service you can
see uh plates of some kind of food some
orange juice uh possibly white wine
possibly something else uh in his glass
simon case that uh with a uh with a can
of coke now simon case wasn't fined by
the police boris johnson was rishi
sunaku you can't see in this photo also
was and there's lots of questions why he
got done but he didn't go and so that's
going to be quite an interesting photo
uh going forward we're looking at
another one of the big pictures it's
another image from the same day you can
see boris johnson simon case uh talking
to each other at that event now this uh
is the third one you can see rishi sunak
so he was fined he was fined simon case
we can't see in this one wasn't you can
see the trays of sandwiches here and the
uh what looks like apple juice and
orange juice on the side uh
giving it that kind of uh uh more
relaxed vibe that you see but those are
the key bits of evidence uh about the
event on which boris johnson the prime
minister was fined fifty pounds by uh
police uh and then there's yet one more
photograph you can see him uh the prime
minister going cheers with a can of coke
and a plate uh full of sandwiches now
this is a picture
of another event this is the 13th of
november uh now this is the uh photo
that shows lee kane's leaving do lee
kane of course boris johnson's former
director of communications uh we saw one
photo uh of lee kane's leaving do a
couple of days ago provided by itv news
this is another one uh and it shows uh
boris johnson essentially playing uh
what would look like the role kind of of
host at this event some surprised that
boris johnson wasn't fined for the
events uh at that uh party uh given that
other people in the rooms potentially
some of the people who are blurred out
were fine you can see from a different
angle from what we saw on monday all of
those wine bottles and those uh wine
glasses and what looks like a vodka
bottle perhaps uh are on the table
but you can also see the prime minister
the prime ministerial red box which may
be used in the case for the defense of
the prime minister uh suggesting that he
might have been uh working and here you
can see it just from a different uh
angle uh him looking like he's very much
sort of holding the room giving a speech
and sort of very much in command of
events and there you have uh the toast
at the same event of um lee kane um
and a fourth photo
of that event a little bit more of the
detritus
underneath boris johnson that you can
see and uh another photo of the same uh
event uh there so um those are the
photos in the report we'll get more
details that will come to you uh with
through the afternoon as we go down to
exactly how she discusses uh what went
on there but clear that su grey trying
to point the finger to those at the top
saying there's been some improvement in
the culture
but also
saying that those at the junior end many
of those who were fined uh by the police
80 odd people uh have received fine to
work at the heart of government uh many
of them are junior ones shouldn't bear
the blame but unclear quite what happens
next uh as uh as she says blame should
go to the top but doesn't appear as if
anything will happen to boris johnson
and simon case